we bring in Peter King from NBC's boards
good morning Peter how are you Dan he
would have had two minutes one time out
all he needed to do was go 40 yards and
I don't mean that 40 yards is absolutely
nothing against the decent defense but
come on it's 40 yards Aaron Rodgers it's
a timeout and that is if the Packers
miss the playoffs by one game which they
very well could looking at the
difficulty of their schedule they missed
the playoffs by one game everybody in
that in that building really is gonna be
seeking that time on gummer e cost us
the playoffs but you can also go back to
Matthews with the sack that was called
you know the penalty that was called and
that cost him a game too so they they've
had two games that they could have had
in in pocket in hand here and that would
have been huge because you're not gonna
have home-field advantage with the Rams
and/or the Saints so it's gonna be tough
sledding you know to begin with for that
team but do you think that time
Montgomery was going to be traded prior
to that kickoff do you think that his
days were numbered in Green Bay well he
had become RB 3 in Green Bay so if he
had stayed it would have been strictly
her I think insurance and and he would
have been a spare part but certainly I
think what happened on Sunday
accelerated I know the cameras are
always on the star players but you know
Aaron Rodgers didn't hide his
dissatisfaction I mean he was he was
upset with it Dan Marino used to do this
all the time and people would either say
well he's a fiery leader or you know
what you're embarrassing your teammates
out there how does this play with
Rodgers when he he shows this kind of
emotion or he says what he has to say
about the play calling in Green Bay I
don't think he cares I think he is so
secure both in his job and in his
position on the team that I mean in my
opinion I think Aaron Rodgers really had
to swallow hard the other day when he
met the press afterwards to not I don't
want
want to say explode but and I think it
it sort of comes with a long time ago I
remember Bernie Kosar when he was at the
time he was a very very prominent player
with the Browns and I remember him
saying to me I made some comment to him
like you know you always say the right
thing a half hour after the game when
you stand there for 20 minutes and and
talk the press and he goes that's the
fifth quarter and I said what do you
mean and he goes because when you're the
quarterback of a team everybody is
looking at you everybody is listening to
you and you have to set the tone in
those days it was what he what he said
is guys are gonna read the paper the
next day to see what the coach and the
quarterback think and how we're feeling
and so we have to be good we always have
to be good and I think it's it's
incumbent on aaron rodgers to sort of
skate on that line but i do think one of
the things that the packers like about
aaron rodgers his teammates like about
him is that he's a no BS guy if and i
was there today in training camp where
he called his wide receivers out you
know for running crappy routes and so i
the only reason i bring that up is that
i think sometimes when you skate on the
edge of being critical of somebody as
rodgers did after the game on that there
is this thing brewing inside of him that
he's really ticked off yeah but i get
that feeling that there's i know that
the knee is not good and probably is
gonna need attention in the offseason it
just feels like that friction with him
and mike mccarthy is untenable i I just
I feel like there's there's a divorce
coming up here at the end of the season
no matter how this plays out your
thoughts you know it could be it could
be and and I think that if the Packers
don't make the playoffs you're
definitely gonna have to watch Green Bay
because no longer is this status quo Ted
you know this isn't the Ted Thompson
show you know Brian gudykunst ooh
likes Mike McCarthy but I don't think is
going to judge where they are as a team
and where Aaron Rodgers is the
approaches it's mid-30s yeah I had an
NFL scout tell me yesterday that he sees
this playing out with McCarthy ending up
in in Cleveland with his relation I mean
a lot of people are you know a lot of
people are doing 2 plus 2 because Dorsey
is yummy there but just remember one
thing and I'm not saying that it won't
happen at all
okay it could happen but I just remember
one thing McCarthy was not necessarily a
you know all those guys who were in
Green Bay with Ron Wolf guys you know
John Schneider John Dorsey Ted Thompson
those are guys who you know we're sort
of Menino they they went to the they
went to the Ted Thompson school Ovie ron
wolf and I'm not sure that Mike McCarthy
you know that that people look at the
coaches who coach their you know Mike
Sherman Mike McCarthy or as you
necessarily Green Bay guys so to speak
as you know that that that is it's
convenient to link them no question
about it because obviously they did work
together but I'm not sure it's a lock I
would I'd also look at at places where
John Dorsey really really likes the
football program likes the coaches
there's no question he respects the
Oklahoma program he spends a lot of time
their scouting or has spent a lot of
time there scouting and I have no idea
what his relationship is with Lincoln
Riley but Lincoln Riley appears to me to
be a guy who's going to get some
interest after this season and maybe not
just from Cleveland he's Peter King NBC
NBC sports.com and if I'll columnist and
you can read his great column that's a
football morning in America every Monday
exclusively NBC sports.com
yeah the mess in Cleveland like why now
with you know
hiring both coaches let alone just one
that's a great question I think it's
because and this I think says more about
how the organization didn't like Todd
Haley then it said about the
organization's feelings about Hugh
Jackson because it would have been very
logical to let Hugo and to keep Todd
Haley as the offensive coordinator with
Greg Williams is the interim coach but I
think they felt like Greg Williams basis
basically should be the head coach and
and didn't want to set the position and
set the stage for any more friction than
there already had been this year and so
it's like you know Todd Haley doesn't
play well with others
that's that's you know the storyline
coming out of Cleveland but but I also
think this man I think what happened on
Monday is that Hugh Jackson wanted and
felt like he should have till the end of
the year and that he should not have
gone before the end of the year and I
think I think if he had his druthers
he'd still be there and Todd Haley
wouldn't be but I think they felt like
okay you're 336 and one you brought in
Todd Haley in the offseason it didn't
work and you've got to pay for that
decision did you like the Rams move or
the Eagles or the Texans better if I'd
mentioned just those three I like the
Rams most you know it does in my opinion
here's what this is you have a supremely
motivated guy in Dante Fowler Jr who
never has played up to his potential for
a variety of reasons in Jacksonville and
now has eight games and one playoff
month to prove that he should be paid
like a Miles Garrett or you know a
premier pass rusher he has not been that
and so he's going to be motivated in the
next three months
to play like the guy who was drafted so
high and that's why to me I look at this
and I think that especially because of
what the Rams
need they need that edge rusher and they
have a very good defense up the middle
you know obviously with great defensive
tackles and Mark Baron you know as a run
stuffing safety slash linebacker thanks
they need an outside rusher and I think
he's gonna provide that what about the
Eagles with golden team love that move
because I think Golden Tate felt like he
was being underutilized I mean here's a
guy who caught more passes in the last
four years and then I think anybody
other than Jarvis Landry coming into
this year and he just wasn't used all
that much my feeling Dan is that Golden
Tate is one of these he's just a
football player he's you know he's an
Edelman type who just put him out there
and he's gonna find a way to get open
and get yards and I think Kenny Kenny
gala day had passed him in terms of the
pecking order in Detroit and they felt
like he wasn't going to be back there
next year so I understand why Detroit
did this but the Lions losses the Eagles
game does Le'Veon Bell show up I mean
what a totally totally ridiculous story
and I mean look it's this is Dan this is
really the classic case in my opinion
classic case of a player who sits out to
force an organization's hands and then
the worst thing happened for him the
team not only got along well without him
they might have gotten along better
without him than with him because who
knows what would have happened to the
chemistry on that team you know if he
came in with you know you know when it
was rumored that he would or he wouldn't
you know you've got a bunch of players
there who I think are kind of bitter
about him you know because they thought
he would be there at the beginning of
the year and
so now you know we'll see what happens
my gut feeling is obviously he wants to
be a free agent so he's going to come in
sometime in the next week or so but I
mean it's a classic Parcells saying they
don't sell insurance for this kind of
stuff best trade rumor you heard you
mean that didn't happen yeah proud I
mean and that's why the rumors and
rumors I thought that the Patriots might
go get you Norris Jenkins and I think
the Giants really wanted to move to
Norris Jenkins but there was nobody out
there who was gonna take that money off
their hands yeah I thought I was told
the Patriots
we're probably gonna surprise people at
the trade deadline and then they didn't
then I saw the Boston Globe where Ben
Bowlin said that they were they're
probably stockpiling
these these picks because they're gonna
go craps all in on taking a quarterback
in 2019 well just think of this Dan that
last year in April in draft week where
was Josh McDaniels on Monday of that
week Josh McDaniels was in the home I
think it was somewhere in Texas of Baker
Mayfield and if the draft had gone
differently
the Patriots might have you know tried
to move heaven and earth to move up to
let's say seven or ten or whatever to
get Baker Mayfield now would they have I
don't know but I think it's interesting
that came out draft week that McDaniels
had spent some time with him and you
know so but I don't doubt that at all
they now have four picks of their own in
the first three rounds plus they will
get a third-round compensatory pick for
both the loss of Nate's older and mouth
of Butler so if you've got six picks in
the top 100 which is what they will have
now all of a sudden it makes it possible
even if you're picking let's say 30 or
wherever I don't know where they'll be
if they're picking 30th overall in the
first round
now you can tack
it's three or four of those pics move up
the ways of falcons once moved up 20
spots or julio jones and you should be
able to go up and get one of the
quarterbacks you know say in the in the
top 10 of this draft good stuff is
always Pete we appreciate your time safe
travels thanks for joining us thank you
Peter King NBC sports.com and his Monday
Morning Quarterback it's football
morning in America NBC sports.com for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]